[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he used to kick footballs now he kicks
ass he's pat mcafee host of the pat
mcafee show along with aj hawk on
youtube and siriusxm the uh former
punter for the colts
uh more likely to get injured punting
or
being a combatant in wwe
hey dan thanks for having me on yeah uh
thanks for always being a trailblazer
you know i mean you're such a smooth
talking guy and you have such a big
brain like whenever you did that read
for link soul before you went to break
there i was on here i was like damn i
need that stuff you know what i mean
like i was like damn i need some link
soul and did you say laser fitted some
sort of thing in that whole i'm like
yeah damn i need link so and then you
just cut a promo for benzo there on the
other side i'm like ah i think we need
to buy them or say you're costing me a
lot of money dan it's because of how
good you are at your job so i appreciate
the invite anytime fritzy's name pops up
on my cell phone i get excited because
obviously we take um you know great
pride in the fact that we're in this
daily sports talk world and you're
obviously a pioneer of it so thank you
for the invite here uh with that being
said almost died a couple times at
summerslam on saturday dan that's and
i've never almost died punting so i i
would go with summerslam and wwe as
opposed to punting but both certainly a
lot of fun a blast in high anxiety
situations but if i talk to you at 12
do you want to be a punter or would you
want to be in wwe wwe for sure and never
wanted to be a punter i mean obviously
nobody you you follow to punter dan i
mean we all know that you know you've
never you've never uh
went up to a kid
and said hey well you won't be when you
grow up and they say like astronaut or a
cop or a fireman or a baseball player a
footballer nobody goes i want to be a
punter in the nfl because if you have
dreams or dreams or aspirations of being
a punter you probably kick the hell out
of a football or a ball so you probably
want to be a soccer player you know and
if you're in a wide receiver or a
quarterback or a tight end that
inevitably ends up being a punter that's
because your team told you like hey this
position ain't gonna work for you you
should probably go try fourth downs and
punting balls so at 12 definitely want
to be a wwe superstar my entire life i
want to be a wwe superstar that's really
the longest stream i've ever had getting
to play in the nfl was a massive
massive honor so thankful for that but
wwe has been the thing that i've won in
my entire life dan were you a position
player before you became a punter no i
was a soccer player i'd show up on
fridays i just kind of walk in with the
fans the first game i had no idea really
how to put on my pads i walked in with
our student section because i had a
soccer game before it
walked across the field had really no
idea what was going on just started
bombing balls like i was the guy nigel
from replacements i um i was very
fortunate to grow up in pittsburgh a
football town so growing up i played a
lot of football on the streets and
backyards and things like that nfl was
my favorite sport to watch but i was
supposed to be a soccer player and then
football just happened after a punt
passing kick national championship and i
happen to have a cannon attached to my
right hip
when did it change for you in this
business when did it click
that you went from a somebody wanted to
do it you were doing stand-up comedy
like you're trying to figure all this
out after your career
but then it clicked
what changed
i don't know dan honestly i have no idea
i think when i was playing in the nfl i
was doing all this stuff so
i had a podcast when i was in the nfl
i did uh a one stand-up comedy tour with
a couple other side shows while i was in
the nfl i had a merch business while i
was in the nfl i um was i was very
fortunate to uh do the bob and tom show
weekly when i was in the nfl as well
so i kind of got a chance to dabble in a
lot of different stuff while i was still
playing and when you're a punter you're
able to do that you know there's no
addendums going into any punter
contracts about watching more film
outside of the facility so with less
mental management on the plate for me
for being a punter i was able to do a
lot of stuff and i just started getting
real fulfillment from everything i was
doing off the field and i found out that
there was a business side to it as well
that i could maybe make some money off
the field as well so once i kind of
reset everybody's finances around my
family and friends the nfl i was super
pumped to be there but i knew that
afterwards i was going to enjoy life as
well and i've obviously gotten
incredibly lucky with this entire run
thus far but i remember we had you on
after you made your decision that might
have been the houston super bowl
and
you said you could still punt
but you were done like how mentally do
you get to the point where you go
i'm done with this
i don't know i mean it's just like
punting like you said whenever you're 12
years old you think about punting no
like even in college i was a kicker
first before i was a punter i became a
punter basically out of necessity and
we're doing the rugby punt which was a
roll out to the right and i was just
trying to line drive it as far as
possible we'd be in games and i have
nothing but respect for all the punters
in the nfl i love them i put them over
every single weekend because it's not an
easy thing to do it is a difficult thing
to do you don't really get a chance to
bounce back either if you have a bad rep
you got to go sit on that for like 35
minutes but in the fourth quarter you
know you're down 21 like a partner can't
do anything like i'm just standing there
i'm along for the ride just like
everybody else in soccer i was like a
point man on basically every team i was
on even when i was kicking at west
virginia and punting in west virginia i
was at least in the game it just got to
a point where after eight years i got a
chance to get really good at the craft i
got to learn a lot i got to experience
great teams and great teammates and i
understand the value of field position
and the sport that i've watched my
entire life and didn't really fully
comprehend uh but i just my brain is
super active super active every day i'm
sitting in there because there's not a
lot of film for us to watch as punters
so i'm playing cornhole for like three
hours in the locker room where everybody
else is watching film and doing all that
and my brain is just running with like a
thousand ideas like i should be doing
this i should be doing this i could be
doing this i could be doing this and you
always think the grass is greener on the
other side you never truly know so for
like three years i contemplated retiring
and just kind of attacking life outside
of football and i don't think it was
until
you know kind of took care of everybody
you know me and the gm didn't get along
he didn't like he didn't think i was
funny i mean that was very pretty
apparent he did not he did not enjoy me
it just there was i was staring down
another knee surgery it just felt like
it just felt like the universe was
telling me dad you know and obviously it
could have got to a point where the
universe was completely wrong and i
still feel like i could probably go punt
for a couple teams if i wanted to uh and
that would probably last for at least
another few years as i'm almost
hey
i'm almost 40 now i mean i'm 35 but damn
i'm getting old dan so i don't know i
just i felt like the universe told me
the timing was right and uh
i was i got very fortunate with the team
i had i mean it was just it was the
perfect timing and i'm very very
fortunate for it all is pat mcafee host
of the pat mcafee show and uh former
colts punter what was your reaction and
um i guess
immediate reaction when you heard that
andrew luck was going to retire
so i was watching at home just like
everybody else right and uh
i mean that's what he comes out of
nowhere fourth quarter preseason game oh
and then obviously the stadium there's a
couple hundred people in there still who
have made it through a preseason game uh
to the fourth quarter one in which
andrew luck was not playing who is our
franchise player so maybe a little
boozed up we could assume and they boo
andrew on his way out and i think it was
more so booing the situation not andrew
because i've never met anybody in
indianapolis that didn't have the utmost
respect for andrew luck because i got to
see it firsthand you know that dude took
an ass beating i mean just on a regular
basis and it was just his style of play
and he would thank everybody that hit
him and he never got too fired up with
people that would obviously blatantly
miss blocks for him to get hit i've
always said i thought he was too nice of
a guy the most talented most talented
person i think i've ever seen his brain
is so large you have to use context
clues just to kind of keep up with
conversations with him right i'm a i'm
an idiot but that it really felt like
that he was so smart so incredibly smart
so athletic he was so good at
quarterback he understood the playbook
quicker than anybody else he had a
photographic memory he's fast he's tough
he's all these things i just think his
style of play and him not being a
mean enough person like i always said i
wish he could watch peyton for one year
if he could have watched peyton not the
peyton was mean but peyton demanded and
commanded respect and also like hey this
is a business this is who i want to do
business with andrew was still like hey
i'm a high school college football
player at the beginning uh you do the
coaching you do the deciding i'll do the
playing i wish you would have took a
little bit more ownership which i think
he did towards the end of his career
which is a natural thing uh but i was
lucky to watch that guy and my first
reaction whenever he retired was damn
the league is going to miss him because
of how explosive and electrifying he was
on the field
the kyler murray story you got deshaun
watson's story like how do you pick and
choose what you dive into and what you
don't on your show
how do you guys do it dan what do you
guys do
i find
and i i asked the danettes i just say
what are you hot on because if if we are
hot on it then i then i think you know i
can buy into it or vice versa and then
the audience is going to trust you
because they tune in already trusting
you
and i think that what i want to know is
what is something that's really
important to somebody here because if
you know we could go down the list and
go is anybody interested in that yeah
how about that no oh that and then the
room reacts and then i sort of take
i grab that that's the baton and then i
take it and then it's up to me to run
the uh you know four by four hundred
well and you do that very well by the
way you run the hell out of a thing like
a gazelle but the i think that's the
right move because you guys are so
established in the ogs in this whole
thing you know you guys are the trend
setters so rich rodriguez gave a
motivational speech to our team one time
and he said he wants a team full of
thermostats you know not thermometers
you know we set the temperature we don't
tell it and it was like it was so
profound whenever he said it and i
assume we were getting i assume we're
getting yelled at for it but i found
that to be like such a profound
statement and i think when we were
starting we were trying to look at what
everybody else was talking about you
know we were trying to watch every other
sports talk show who we assumed had
better scouts better producers more
equipped to talk about what we should be
talking about and that lasted i don't
know probably four months five months
and then we got to the point where much
like you we go what do we want to talk
about you know and if if our
conversations are good like if you build
it they will come as kind of the hopes
and but sometimes we miss some stuff
that everybody else is chatting about
strictly because we're either too dumb
to talk about that particular thing or
it literally never came up in our
universe and we completely missed it
would you use steroids
in the wwe
to make your body look
you know like like ultimate warrior like
you know one of those i mean i can see
you you're kind of jacked
jocked thank you
but you know but like an actor you know
these guys in hollywood they'll use
performance-enhancing drugs
you're an actor with wwe
would you consider you're a performer
would you consider steroids so they have
a a whole wellness policy over at the
wwe because of i think what you are
alluding to where there is
you know they drug test rather
often at the wwe yes they they actually
do now there's always going to be people
that talk about some people maybe aren't
getting tested there's always conspiracy
theories about everything but i've been
tested and given my blood to the wwe
numerous times so now this isn't part of
your standup act you're being serious
right you're not
100 because it was by the way there's a
lot of things that happen whenever you
start injecting your body with stuff and
people who are already maybe high energy
or very emotional and then there was
some stuff that has happened through the
evolution of human and the evolution of
wwe where they have had to put in
different rules and evolve hopefully you
know and i i think the wellness policy
is a big one because of all the things
that you are uh kind of i think
immediately thinking of now with that
being said
when i was in the nfl
and we'd see a guy walk into the locker
room who was obviously on something that
the rest of us
would not take because of a failed test
there was an immediate chatter out of my
brain like well as soon as i retire i'm
getting on whatever that
guy is on you know i'm getting on
whatever that person's on and you'd see
somebody come with you
walking in just yoked out of their mind
i'm like okay so that's just what you're
just drinking protein shakes and stuff
and then ha ha laughs
i'm like i'm gonna get into that so i
think as i've grown older i have uh
found two things difficult to find in
indiana where i live it's not just
something you walk up to a corner store
and say hey i'm looking to look like
this guy that walked into the locker
room when i was playing what do i need
to take and also i think i'm starting to
think more about life you know i thought
i was going to die young for a long time
i was burning that thing from both ends
real hard i think it's well documented i
think everybody knows that but now that
i'm getting older i'm trying to you know
take care of myself a little bit and i
don't know if i just want to shove
everything that horses take into their
bodies into mine but if science gets to
a point where it's healthy and safe and
it's not going to kill me too young i
will certainly take something that'll
make my metabolism be uh a little bit
quicker like it used to be my recovery
time a little bit but i haven't delved
into those waters just yet dan patrick
what does your wife say when she sees
you on stage you know with
you know kind of showing off your body
hey my wife's sweet man we just
celebrated our second anniversary
yesterday and uh
thank you
thank you paulie you had the uh the
under oh i lost big big fake that's big
yeah oh you aren't the only one
you aren't the only one i think uh
you know i i've always
i don't know man i'm just a goer i
always have been dan just go go go go go
go go and i rarely have any beef with
anybody because i'm not around long
enough to have beef with anybody i'm
normally just in and out here we go
what's next what's next i've been very
driven my entire life i think anybody
that's ever known me would know that
i've been trying to become successful
literally forever so i'm always thinking
like what's next what are we doing hey
how we doing let's keep it moving and my
wife is
the first person that ever like
i think tried to be like hey you're
allowed to like hang out for a bit like
you're allowed to
like i'm not just gonna let you just
walk out of my life like this is so i
don't want to say she tamed
you know the stallion here but she kind
of did she kind of and she's a super
supportive person of me she understands
that i've had these dreams a lot longer
than we've ever known each other so she
is
fantastic uh she is a great cook though
so every once in a while i'll get into
good shape i'm like taking care of
myself and then i'll come home and
there's just like these cinnamon rolls
and like these chocolate chip cookies
and all this stuff and i am i have no
discipline i will dive in there dan so
it's a team effort so i think she's
pumped about it all does she ever just
say shut up
oh yeah what are you talking about i
mean i've been with me for 35 years i
say it to me all the time i i couldn't
even imagine what she says uh but you
have a better body than peyton manning's
i think we could agree with that right
yeah i don't know his body uh took him
to a hall of fame i think he's not his
body of work his body
well i mean his body is his
tool what are you talking about no his
mind his mind
oh yeah but have you those hey those
wobbly balls ain't going to throw
themselves
what do you think this is
no uh quarterbacks i don't i don't think
and it's kind of changing now with the
evolution of offense and what
quarterbacks can do
but back in the day there was a lot of
bad body quarterbacks you know and they
actually like
all of them you basically go through all
of them bad body i mean because they
wanted to keep their muscles loose like
a basketball shooter or a golfer like
guys didn't want to get too yolked up
because they thought they would mess up
their throw so now it's all
it's a little bit of a different game
where guys got to take hits i think
they're getting a little bit more
yoked up but i think peyton had a uh a
solid body and a body of work obviously
yes he did it's like roethlisberger
roethlisberger he had big head syndrome
go through them all any of those pocket
quarterbacks probably had a hilarious
upper body i mean the lower body is
going to be strong core probably going
to have to be strong right because
there's a lot of that and um you know
throwing but normally arms chest traps
neck
pretty relaxed and that's normally how
people are uh judging bodies or not you
know what i mean dan
give me uh give me double gun shot here
before we go here
let's see let's see what we got here let
me wake him up wake up wake up wake up
it feels good man i'll tell you what my
knees are still sore though uh
knees still sore i i still gain like 25
30 pounds and lose 25 30 pounds like
every two three months when football
season is coming around just like i'm
still playing but i'm incredibly pumped
about where life is and i can't thank
you all enough honestly hey congrats no
for trailblazing in this world and also
let's win it let's get you guys a damn
emmy what are we doing paul fritz seton
boyce what the hell is going on over
there how come these shows that are just
johnny come lately okay
johnny come lately
childish stuff are winning emmys and you
guys aren't what is the deal
where the buffalo bills of of uh of
emmys no you're not because you guys
have a kicker that's gonna make the kick
oh and that that happens every single
time i don't understand
what the deal is what is just is it
because you're too handsome dan you
think it's because you're too handsome
oh gosh that's what they've told me that
before that
yeah
i think you're right i mean it's like
you know you don't want to have a
comedian who's good looking
you know not relatable yeah right see so
so you are too handsome for sporting
sucks i think even though your show how
many years how many years you've been
doing uh well we've been together 16
years since i left the mothership
how how do you how have you done 16 off
seasons i just got through what my third
one oh my god there is no off season
yes there is or you cut i was trying to
find out what i heard
that a jury or a grand jury would indict
a ham sandwich that's what i was told
okay i'm trying to learn these legalese
stuff and then for two three weeks i'm
talking about litigation i have no idea
about any i don't know how you did it
dan you're too smart i'm not smart
enough for it all pal
tell aj i said hello congrats again
great to talk to you buddy thank you so
much for having me it's always an honor
i will tell aj i'm sure he says hi
that's pat mcafee host of the pat mcavee
show co-hosted by aj hawk you can find
it on youtube and sirius xm